so wait who is louder at t-ball games is
it you or John it's me for sure okay
yeah I I grew up watching I kind of
don't know why I asked you that question
because he is like walking Ambien to me
thank you
thank you he's very chill I know it's
just and he's no he's just super chill
yeah I don't think he's ever gotten mad
at me like truly I really don't like I
mean he has but he doesn't show it at
least but like yeah it's pretty wild he
is very even kill yeah I gotta he should
write a book yeah I know but people like
us and then everyone's like yeah people
like that though it's festering and it's
gonna burst I'm like no it's not in
there it's like yeah really just not
yeah he's very chill yeah so I don't
even know why I asked you that no that's
of course you're the one at the game
because he's probably just like
like he does a nod yeah and plus I'm not
sure if he like I love baseball so much
and and he's just like kind of a yeah
he's passive with he doesn't mind he's
one of those people that's like I want
both teams to win like even in football
and stuff so
um yeah I but I love I love hyping
everybody up though like the other team
they're four and five so come on yeah
yeah that's so cute I love these like
everyone's a while
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]